encuentra el mínimo común múltiplo de 15
x 20 x cuadrada más 5 x cuando tienes
que encontrar el mínimo común múltiplo
de un grupo de números tienes que
dividir cada uno de los números en
partes pequeñas cuando estamos hablando
de números no de expresiones algebraicas
y no en números las partes más pequeñas
en las cuales puedes separar un número
las encuentras haciendo su factorización
en números primos pero si estás tratando
con expresiones algebraicas las tienes
que descomponer en sus factores más
simples aunque en realidad a éstos no se
les puede llamar factores primos
tratemos de hacerlo y cuando hacemos eso
el mínimo común múltiplo es la misma
expresión que puede ser descompuesta en
esos factores y solo tiene estos
factores así que factor hicimos cada uno
de estos empecemos con 15 x 15 x lo
podemos escribir como 15
por equis y 15 lo podemos actualizar
hagamos una facturación de primos aquí
esto es 3 por 5
ambos son números primos así es que
quince equipos factorizar como tres por
cinco por equis y este la factorización
de 15 x bueno hemos hecho la
descomposición en primos del coeficiente
del número 15 en cuanto a la equis no
podemos reducirla más no podemos
llamarle propiamente primo es una
variable hagamos lo mismo para 20
entonces 20 se puede factorizar como 2
por 10 y 10 se puede factorizar como 2
por 5
así es que 20 lo podemos escribir como 2
por 2 por 5 y eso es una factorización
en primos directa hagamos ahora x
cuadrada más 5 x x cuadrada más 5 x
ambos términos son divisibles entre x
así es que esto es igual a x que
multiplica a x cuadrada más 5 dividiendo
x cuadrada entre x nos queda x y
dividiendo 5x entre x
5 así es que el mínimo común múltiplo
déjame escribirlo aquí abajo el mínimo
común múltiplo es la mínima expresión
que contiene a todos estos términos que
hemos factor izado aquí empecemos
entonces con los números y luego iremos
a las variables tiene que tener al menos
22 es aquí tenemos 22 es no tenemos 2 es
por acá pero aquí tenemos 2 2 es
entonces tiene que tener 22 de cárcel o
en el mismo rosa en el que están tiene
que tener 22 es si es divisible entre 20
tiene que tener al 5 pero ese lo
incluiremos en un momento ahí tenemos 22
es tiene que tener al menos un 3 si
queremos que sea divisible entre 15 x
tiene que tener al menos un 3 vamos a
incluirlo en el mínimo común múltiplo no
hay 13 saca incluimos al 3 tiene que
tener un 5 si queremos que sea divisible
entre 15 x tiene que tener un 5 y
también si queremos que sea divisible
entre 20 tiene que incluir un 5 aquí lo
tenemos el 5 vamos a incluirlo aquí
abajo 5 que hace que el número ya sea
divisible
15 y entre 20 aunque no hemos incluido
todos los factores ahí el número ya es
divisible entre 20 aunque no es
divisible aún entre 15 x es divisible
entre 15 pero aún no lo es entre 15 x
porque aquí no tenemos una equis como ya
hemos incluido el 3 por 5 es divisible
entre 15 aquí lo tenemos 3 por 5 vamos a
las variables aquí tenemos una equis
vamos a incluir esa equis en el mínimo
común múltiplo por equis y este número
es divisible entre 15 x de hecho aquí lo
tenemos 3 por 5 15 por x 15 x también es
un número divisible entre 20 aquí
tenemos 2 por 24 por 520 es divisible
entre x por x 5 bueno la equis ya la
hemos incluido pero no tenemos x + 5
tenemos que incluir entonces x + 5 vamos
a incluir lo vamos a ponerlo en naranja
el mínimo común múltiplo también
requiere x + 5 así es que este es el
mínimo común múltiplo vamos a
multiplicar para simplificar esto dos
por dos es cuatro por tres es 12
12 x 5 12 x 5 es 60 60 x x 60 x así es
que esto es igual a 60 x que multiplica
a x más 5 y vamos a desarrollar este
producto 60 x x x 60 x cuadrada estoy
distribuyendo 60 x 60 x x 5 es 300 x y
aquí lo tenemos
este es el mínimo común múltiplo